les jurés des assises du val-de-marne
acquittent le policier laignel en
juillet 86 il avait tué william normand
un motard qui tentait de lui échapper le
grand exode sur les routes dans les
aéroports et dans les gares ça devait
bouchonné ça bouchonne l'infirmière
atteintes du sida en 84 après un
accident de manipulation est mort le cas
est exceptionnel mais le mot d'ordre
dans les hôpitaux est désormais
précaution loyer une troisième loi en
sept ans le gouvernement se donne le
moyen de limiter par décret les os
par exemple à paris le tour de france
sur antenne 2 demain prologue version
européenne au luxembourg il ya cette
année 220 forçats de la grande boucle
madame monsieur bonsoir la cour
d'assises du val-de-marne a donc
acquitté eric laignel 26 ans jugé pour
avoir tué un motard qui prenaient la
fuite à fontenay sous bois
le 31 juillet 1986 le jury qui a
délibéré une heure a suivi un
réquisitoire modérée de l'avocat général
le verdict n'a pas été accueillie dans
la sérénité
la famille de la victime a manifesté sa
colère alors que certains policiers
présents exprimer eux leur satisfaction
en applaudissant sur place pour antenne
2 and gas burget bernie mériaux ton
frère la perpet au soutien à perpète
aussi prairies
des bâtards je marche le cul des vosges
à vous devez juger un homme de chair et
de sang et non un symbole avait prévenu
l'avocat général ces sommes sont armés
par l'état et celui ci est un garçon
remarquable
le réquisitoire a évoqué le modèle
laignel ici lors de la reconstitution un
policier qui n'a jamais jouer aux cow
boys héritent laignel dans le box des
accusés et rester tout l'après midi
cassé en deux le regard à terre face à
lui accablé dans la même attitude la
famille de william normand qui entoure
une petite femme en deuil
elle craque lorsque l'on évoque son
williams être fragile insiste l'avocat
général qui ne parlait jamais à personne
s'affirmer en terrorisant les gens le
voleur de sac c'était bien lui dit-il
l'homme à la moto dont il détaille
l'agonie la mer les 20 points vengeurs
l'avocat général conclut laignel a tiré
parce qu'il avait peur mais cela ne
suffit pas pour justifier la légitime
défense c'est pourtant ce qu'a plaidé
maître garrot avec une passion teinté
d'humour grinçant
c'est un bon flic pas le super rambo
faut-il attendre que les flics soient
flinguer dans leur top 9 par des motards
dangereux normand le provocateur avait
choisi de vivre dangereusement
justice a été rendue est pour moi bien
rendue et je pense que cette décision
pour les miels évidemment capital mais
elle redonnera également confiance aux
forces de police dont nous avons tant de
secours équipements
fille pour la famille que la vie de leur
fils et sans valeur parce qu'elle est
opposée au destin la policière devant
une salle comble eric laniel s'élever
depuis trois ans at il dit je n'ai rien
oublié je n'oublierai jamais je demande
pardon à la famille elle n'a pas
d'accepter 7 millions de personnes sur
les routes nous vous le disions d hier
ajoutez-y 250 mille voyageurs pour 418
trains en circulation demain il y as
record de départ avec bien sûr les
premiers embouteillages notamment à lyon
où les difficultés devrait être
amplifiée par des opérations escargots
des chauffeurs de taxi à lyon nous
retrouvons henry fourvière et son tunnel
ne sont plus ce qu'ils étaient en fait
un vendredi bien curieux que ce 30 juin
hormis un bouchon tôt ce matin au nord
de la grande cité lyonnaise circulation
tout à fait normal au péage de vienne
aux alentours de 17 heures puis une
heure plus tard à quelques pas de
villefranche-sur-saône images quasiment
identique pour qu'un véritable
ralentissement même les taxis en grève
qui avaient prévu des opérations
escargot ne se sont jusque alors guère
montrés si ce n'est dans le centre de
lyon il semble donc bien que le gros des
troupes des vacanciers ne se soit pas
encore manifestée en attendant
l'ancienne capitale des gaules peut sans
dormir tranquillement demain risque fort
d'être une autre affaire mais ce soit en
tout cas on part assez mal de paris
comme les autres week-ends et bien sûr
en plus avec ce week-end qui est un
week-end de départ en vacances
attendez en tout cas dimanche je vous le
rappelle pour partir surveillez aussi
les compteurs des pompes dans les
stations service la direction des
hydrocarbures annonce que le prix du
super s'établit en moyenne en france à
saint-front 30 le litre après avoir
baissé dans les 10 derniers jours
hier nous évoquions le dossier de
l'essence propres de l'essence sans
plomb ce matin sur l'antenne de madame
neiertz secrétaire d'état à la
consommation
inciter les automobilistes à la patience
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit clairement établi
qu'ils peuvent utiliser sans risque ces
nouveaux carburants derniers aspects de
ce dossier
l'essence sans plomb c'est aussi un
nouvel épisode de la guerre entre les
pétroliers et les grandes surfaces
eve m'étais patrick gabet
nouveau supercarburant semblant
en août dernier 98 qu'ils voient ces
publicités les patrons des grandes
surfaces grincent des dents
ils ont compris l'astuce des compagnies
pétrolières dans la guerre des
carburants jusqu'à présent c'était
plutôt les grandes surfaces qui gagnait
depuis 1985 où les prix de l'essence ont
été libérés elles ont croqué peu à peu
le marché par des prix bas jusqu'à
détenir 40 % de la distribution
aujourd'hui mais total shell esso et les
autres ont trouvé la parade
le super super sans plomb 98 qu'il lance
demain sera disponible uniquement dans
leurs réseaux de stations-service
on ne pourra pas le trouver dans les
hypermarchés compagnie pétrolière
française pour échapper à la guerre des
prix ont décidé de commercialiser un
euro 98 à fort renfort publicitaire
donc nous voulons maintenant en avoir il
ya un monopole du raffinage en france
elles sont pas pressés de vous en livrer
certaines veuves refuse de nous en
livrer c'est une polémique qui va finir
devant le conseil de la concurrence chez
les pétroliers on défend haut et fort
l'exclusivité normal dit on de ce
produit haut de gamme élaborée par nos
soins ne soit vendu que sous nos marques
si ceci est interprété quelque chose
contre les grandes surfaces peut-être ce
qu'il ya une espèce de culpabilité chez
les grandes surfaces et je ne sais pas
mais en ce qui nous concerne ce n'est
pas une guerre c'est simplement notre
métier de professionnel distribution
sous la marque n'a rien de scandaleux
prenons l'exemple des eaux minérales une
eau minérale
qu'il s'agisse de vittel ou déviants ou
de contrex et distribués dans des
bouteilles qui portent l'étiquette de la
marque heures c'est vrai que les grandes
surfaces ont l'habitude de la
distribution sélective
les grandes marques de prêt à porter ou
de parfum par exemple refusent d'être
vendus dans les hypermarchés pour garder
leurs images des textes de loi autorise
ces pratiques sous diverses conditions
mais pour les sens le secrétaire d'état
à la consommation pense qu'il doit en
être autrement
ce que je crois important en matière de
carburant sans plomb c'est qu'il n'y ait
pas de distribution sélective que les
consommateurs puissent trouver du sans
plomb dans toutes les stations service
quelles qu'elles soient et quelle que
soit la marque que ce soit des stations
de grandes marques que ce soit des
stations de grandes surfaces pour
l'instant les services du ministère de
la consommation n'ont pas trouvé la
faille juridique pour mettre en défaut
les compagnies pendant que les
fonctionnaires planche
les pétroliers font la fête du sans
plomb et les grandes surfaces rongent
leur frein
la voiture le train les avions pendant
ces trois jours plus d'un million de
voyageurs doivent s'envoler pour
d'autres horizons
les aéroports de paris ont programmé
3661 mouvement dont 1434 pour
aujourd'hui
c'est un record absolu patrick esther
effectivement une journée record pour le
trafic aérien
ce soir à 22h30 plus de 1450 avions ont
décollé ou atterri d'orly et de roissy
au total aujourd'hui plus de 5500
appareils auront survolé ou atterri en
france malgré la saturation presque
totale de l'espace aérien
les retards sont restées relativement
limitées 10 à 12 minutes à
l'atterrissage 10 à 15 minutes pro
décollage toutefois sur le secteur sud
est en raison de la grève des
électroniciens du centre régional de
contrôle aérien d'aix les repart à la mi
journée ont atteint 45 minutes voire une
heure
compte tenu de l'affluence des candidats
au voyage 250000 rien que pour orly la
journée s'est relativement bien passée
toutes les normes de sécurité ont été
respectées
une démonstration des compétences et
l'efficacité des contrôleurs aériens
pour eux le week-end sera encore long
mais le cap du vendredi soir où le
trafic d'affaires se cumule avec les
départs en vacances est maintenant
franchie l'an dernier le trafic n'avait
jamais excédé 5200 vol dans la même
journée c'est à dire 300 vols de moins
qu'aujourd'hui
le conflit à la météorologie nationale
une partie du personnel technique en
grève depuis plus de trois semaines a
été notifiée ce matin par la direction
de reprendre le travail pour je cite
assurer la sécurité des personnes dans
cette période de trafics aérien et
routier intense
les crs sont intervenus dans plusieurs
aéroports tous ceux qui ont besoin de
savoir la météo ont dû s'adapter jeu est
bien la pierre la grève de la
météorologie nationale n'empêchera pas
le décollage d'ariane cette nuit kourou
possède son propre centre météo
le manque d'information oblige les
pilotes ont crié à s'informer eux-mêmes
auprès de la tour de contrôle pour le
décollage auprès des centres météo
étrangers pour l'atterrissage en cours
de route ils comptent sur leur radar de
bord en revanche l'aviation légère vol à
vue - game équipe et elle risque la
mauvaise rencontre d'un orage
imprévisible
même problème pour les plaisanciers qui
réapprennent à naviguer en scrutant le
ciel les médias les abonnés à la
météorologie nationale
on t'appelle au centre nucléo des pays
voisins comme s'ils se trompent qui leur
en tient rigueur depuis le 7 juin une
grève qui ne fait pas de bruit
le responsable l'anticyclone des açores
garantie d'un temps calme et stable mais
aujourd'hui les départs en vacances et
le retour des dépressions ont rappelé
les grévistes à l'ordre une partie
d'entre eux a été obligée de reprendre
le travail
aux postes clés le centre de prévisions
parisiens et les aéroports pour raisons
de sécurité
le sida a tué par accident à nida ans
est infirmière de 34 ans qui travaillait
à la pitié salpêtrière à paris
elle s'était piqué en 1984 au cours
d'une manipulation
ce type de contamination est extrêmement
rare on en compte une quinzaine dans le
monde mais il ya désormais un seul mot
d'ordre dans les hôpitaux précaution
marie-françoise griot yves breux
c'est en se piquant accidentellement au
cours d'un prélèvement de sang en
janvier 84 kan'nida aura contracté le
virus du sida
sa mort concrétise aujourd'hui les
craintes de tous médecins des
infirmières qui travaillent au contact
direct des malades séropositifs
c'est un drame que nous redoutons depuis
plusieurs années heureusement peut-on
dire le risque de contamination est
faible c'est un virus fragile peu
contaminants mais les incidents
potentiellement contaminants ne sont pas
exceptionnelles c'est un risque qui est
fait mais qui n'est pas nul et il ya
donc des précautions à prendre
indiscutablement il faut il veiller très
soigneusement il a fallu oublier
certains gestes dangereux comme leur
capuche n'a levé sera qu il a fallu en
apprendre d'autres par exemple jeté tous
les objets souillés dans des containers
spéciaux
le matériel a évolué ils évitent
désormais le contact direct avec le sang
du malade mais il reste d'autres
facteurs plus difficile à maîtriser mois
qu'il faudrait penser aussi au personnel
soignant d'effectifs du personnel
soignant qui est quelquefois en quantité
inférieure compte tenu des besoins de
ces patients sont des patients
extrêmement lourdes par leurs soins et
il est évident que plus les patients
sont lourds une infirmière a du travail
et plus elles risquent de subir la
fréquence des piqûres accidentelles
reste élevée 25 par an dans l'hôpital où
exerçait thani mais le sida ne figure
toujours pas au tableau des maladies
professionnelles
david cyr où le garçon de 13 ans tué
d'une balle en pleine tête mardi dans la
case de son père en isère a été victime
d'une balle perdue c'est en tout cas ce
que démontre l'étude de balistique
david cyr ou et meurent est mort à cause
d'un jeu de guerre et de harcèlement qui
opposait depuis trois ans son père à des
inconnus sur place pour antenne 2 bruno
roger-petit la balle qui a tué le petit
david sireau a transpercé cette tôle
avant de le frapper en pleine pelt
en effet selon les premiers résultats de
l'expertisé balistique
david siro n'était pas visée par le
tireur embusqué à 20 mètres de là un
homicide par ricochet un homicide
involontaire cet après midi un capitaine
de gendarmerie de la section recherches
de grenoble est venu annoncer à robert
cyr ou
autopsie sur le corps de son fils avait
été pratiquée dans la matinée et que le
corps lui serait rendu
une autopsie dont les résultats
viendrait encore compliqué l'enquète la
balle qui a tué david cyr ou n'aurait
pas été retrouvée
pas plus que n'aurait été retrouvée la
douille de cette même balle il serait
par conséquent difficile de retrouver
larmes qui a tué le petit david de même
que le propriétaire de cette arme
ce soir quand bien même il apparaîtrait
que robert cyr ou n'a pas tué lui-même
accidentellement son fils au cours de la
fusillade
personne personne pas même des
enquêteurs ne peut dire qui sont les
mystérieux visiteurs venus attaquer
mardi par ce chemin
la casse de la famille ition
l'organisation nationaliste basque
dissoute iparretarrak a revendiqué
l'attentât perpétré à biarritz sur la
voie ferrée paris madrid attentats plus
spectaculaire que dangereux qui n'a fait
que des dégâts
cela juste quelques heures avant la
visite qu'a effectuée dans la région
pierre joxe le ministre de l'intérieur
qualifie l'attentât de criminels et
d'irresponsables détail et contexte avec
pascal deschamps et philippe etcheverry
un attentat plus spectaculaire que
dangereux
la bombe placée sous le ballast à 300
mètres de la gare de biarritz devait
exploser quelques minutes avant le
départ du paris madrid un attentat
avertissements dijon après celui commis
contre l'hôtel des impôts de bayonne qui
n'avait fait lui aussi que des dégâts
matériels et à quelques heures de
l'arrivée au pays basque du ministre de
l'intérieur venu rencontrer ici puis 250
il
l'occasion pour iparretarrak de rappeler
sa principale revendication la mystique
pour tous les militants basques
emprisonnés adressez vous au garde des
sceaux a dit pierre joxe en substance je
ne suis pas venu pour ça
pensez vraiment qu'à cela moi je vous
assure que je pense à tout autre chose
je suis pas venu ici avec le directeur
général de la police soutenue avec le
directeur de l'administration
gerba et avec le ministre de
l'aménagement du territoire tournez-vous
un peu plus vers l'avenir le plus vers
lui je crois vous ferez un meilleur
investissement en parlant avec chérèque
joxe et les deux ministres n'étaient
certes pas venu les mains vides deux
semaines après les mesures en faveur de
la langue basque
annoncé par lionel jospin il a surtout
été question d'économie aujourd'hui avec
la création d'un conseil de
développement du pays bas
alors mon l'idée d'un conseil du
développement
c'est pour essayer s'il ya vraiment une
identité basque si à notre gênés it et
basse qu'on l'ait un interlocuteur
alors c'est quelque chose à ses quelque
chose à inventer
et comme disait pierre jobin à bout à
vous de faire nous on est nous on est
prêts des mesures économiques et
culturelles que réclamaient les
associations basque depuis de nombreuses
années et qui semblait ce soir bien
accueilli amnesty exclu pour les basses
que disait pierre joxe en revanche
l'assemblée adopte le projet de loi d
amnistie pour les indépendantistes
guadeloupéen et martiniquais deux
amendements de taille votée par les
socialistes et les communistes cet après
midi le bénéfice de cette amnistie
s'étend aux nationalistes corses d'une
part ils sont sept militants encore
détenus et audi militants cgt de renault
billancourt dont la régie refuge depuis
trois ans la réintégration l'aministie
n'implique pas que cette réintégration
soit effective nicolas jacobs les 10 de
billancourt était venu à l'assemblée à
la sortie pas de triomphalisme plutôt
même des visages fermés
pour eux la loi d'amnistié ne signifie
pas encore réintégration ça fait trois
ans que nous menons elle charts mais
très dur qui va il va falloir encore la
médiation pour faire appliquer ce texte
l'amnistié la réintégration des 10 pour
la cgt le parti communiste c'est devenu
un cheval de bataille une lutte
symbolique le licenciement pour faute
lourde a été prononcée il ya trois ans
la suite d'incidents lors de la
séquestration de trois cadres de la
régie l'on passé le tribunal des
prud'hommes ordonne leur réintégration
en vertu de la loi d'aministie de
juillet 88
mais renault soutenu par les cadres fait
appel et finit par obtenir en justice la
confirmation de la sanction ce soir à la
régie on s'abstient de tout commentaire
les avocats sont au travail car
l'amendement laisse un recours possible
il prévoit que les dix doivent être
réintégrés sauf si je cite cela doit
faire peser sur l'employeur des
sacrifices excessif d'ordre personnel ou
patrimoniales l'encadrement cgc lui se
dit atterré alors que le parti
communiste menace de mettre à profit les
festivités du bicentenaire
obtenir la réintégration définitive des
10 pierre mauroy lorgne du côté des
verts ce matin dans libération le
premier secrétaire du ps désir est une
alliance avec les écologistes qu'il
considère comme stratégique
à gauche pierre mauroy parle aussi du
parti communiste comme d'un parti
moribond
réponse cet après midi des écologistes
nous inviter à participer au ps c'est
une hérésie dit antoine waechter
tout cela est bien sûr à resituer dans
le débat interne qui anime le parti
socialiste la veille d'un comité
directeur est à quelques mois d'un
congrès national de mars 90 pas facile
pour le ps de gérer dans le milieu scène
à la fois à l'aspiration de la base et
le pouvoir
vous savez philips est une constante
sous la vème république il n'est pas
aisé d'être le parti du gouvernement le
parti socialiste n'échappe pas à la
règle qui peut difficilement harceler
michel rocard sans atteindre françois
mitterrand pourtant comme il n'y a pas
en vue d'élections nationales pendant
trois ans les uns peuvent se défouler
sans risque les autres faire monter les
enchères dans la tente du grand brassage
d'idées qui aura lieu au congrès du mois
de mars prochain à la veille du comité
directeur de ce week-end qui amoureux a
décidé de donner un coup de barre à
gauche
plus question de soutenir une politique
d'accompagnement des exigences
économiques dit-il histoire de
rasséréner une base socialiste qui
depuis quelques temps montre des signes
de lassitude
la fuite des électeurs vers l'abstention
ou l'écologie pousse d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui le premier secrétaire
appuyée par certains jeunes ultra du ps
a misé sur une alliance avec les verts
face à lac simon roy jospin tous les
leaders du parti socialistes veulent
faire entendre leur différence
il y aura au congrès une contribution
fabius une contribution mermaz les
mitterrandistes le souk ne sont déjà
plus tout à fait d'accord entre eux il y
aura une contribution chevènement une
contribution poperen et très
favorablement une contribution rocard le
premier ministre fort de sa présence à
l'hôtel matignon souhaiterait amplifier
les 30% de mandat qu'il détient au sein
du ps beaucoup de sensibilité
concurrentes donc beaucoup de
rénovations dans l'air c'est sans doute
qu en prévision des échéances futures et
notamment des présidentielles il y a
aujourd'hui au parti socialisme non
seulement des courants de pensée mais
des courants d'arrière-pensées
l'expression et d'un orfèvre en matière
de courants jean pierre chevènement
merci jean louis
l'état se donne un outil dirigiste dans
la nouvelle loi sur le logement adopté
la nuit dernière à l'assemblée il pourra
par décret limiter les hausses de loyer
première application à paris dans les
semaines qui viennent
j'en paye eux la hausse des loyers en
ile de france annoncé le ministre de
l'économie et des finances sera limitée
par décret à 3,3 pour cent pendant un an
le décret est pris en application de la
nouvelle loi sur les loyers voté la nuit
dernière par les députés
la principale disposition de la nouvelle
loi consiste à supprimer pour le
propriétaire la liberté de fixer le
loyer en fin de bail désormais les
hausses de loyers doivent être
justifiées par référence aux loyers du
voisinage quant au congé donné aux
locataires il devra être de nouveau
motivé
faute d'accord c'est d'abord une
commission conciliation puis le juge
d'instance qui comme maintenant décidera
du montant du loyer
les seuls voyait que le propriétaire
pourra fixer librement
sont ce des logements neufs et des
logements vacants ayant fait l'objet de
travaux importants
les baux sont toujours d'une durée de
trois ans si le propriétaire est un
particulier mais de 6 ans désormais si
c'est une banque ou une compagnie
d'assurance une mesure particulière vise
les baux signés depuis décembre 86 les
propriétaires devront proposer un
nouveau bail aux locataires afin qu'ils
bénéficient des dispositions de la
nouvelle loi
à noter que les propriétaires et les
professionnels de l'immobilier s'élèvent
contre la nouvelle loi et craignent
qu'elle ne mette un frein à la
construction privée qu'elle ne fige la
situation du parc immobilier existant à
l'étranger une dernière minute le
général jérusalem ce qui annonce qu'il
n'est pas candidat à la présidence de la
république le numéro un polonais a fait
cette déclaration cet après midi alors
qu'il participait à un plénum du comité
central du parti ouvrier unifié polonais
c'est une surprise puisque le général
gervais ce qui était le seul candidat
c'est le général quitte chaque ministre
de l'intérieur qui devrait être le
candidat du parti communiste à
l'élection présidentielle en pologne
on peut dire dans le contexte de
ce renoncement que le général james qui
avait été contestée dans sa stratégie de
rapprochement et de l'égalisation avec
solidarité d'autres nouvelles de
l'étranger avec la maladie du diplomate
gromyko les exploits de greenpeace est
le énième coup d'état ou soudan et
récupéra aux états au soudan le
gouvernement civil de monsieur sa dette
et m'a dit ça a été renversé par une
junte militaire qui contrôle tous les
points névralgiques de la capitale
khartoum l'armée a suspendu la
constitution interdit les partis
politiques dits sous les syndicats et
retirer les licences journaux l'état
d'urgence a été décrété
les forces rebelles du sud soudan
attendent d'en savoir plus pour réagir
andreï gromyko que l'on voit ici sur des
images d'archivés ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères et ancien chef de
l'état soviétique vient d'être opéré
pour des problèmes vasculaires son état
et de sources officielles satisfaisant
andreï gromyko avait quitté le politburo
en septembre dernier il aura 81 ans le
18 juillet prochain
danger de radiations nucléaires c'est la
signification de ce drapeau que des
activistes de greenpeace ont réussi à
fixer sur un sous marin soviétique en
mer baltique
l'organisation écologiste entend des cas
ainsi protester contre la présence
d'armes nucléaires pan soviétique
américaine dans cette zone
deux cent mille hectares de forêt ont
déjà été détruits par un incendie qui
dure depuis trois semaines à sakhaline
en extrême orient soviétique c'est une
île 20 % de sa surface ont déjà été
détruits l'incendié n'est pas maîtrisé
catastrophe écologique vie la pravda 220
coureurs 76e édition prologue européen
luxembourg demain samedi bien sûr sur
antenne 2 une prime exceptionnelle cette
année à l'homme qui passera en tête le
1780 9e kilomètre vive la révolution
ah oui c'est le tour de france jean
lemaire cette année le tour innove et se
met au goût de l'europe avec un départ
du grand duché du luxembourg
et pourtant cette petite place
financière peut difficilement être taxé
de fièvre du cyclisme
le dernier passage du tour remonte à
1968 et pas un seul coureur
luxembourgeois ne participent à la
compétition
les grands sont étrangers le plus
souvent européens d'ailleurs comme
l'irlandais stephen roche
s'il n'a pas retrouvé la forme il n'a
pas perdu son humour a été bon pour
inclure non
mais la grande star du tour 89 c'est un
autre européen l'espagnol pedro delgado
le récent vainqueur du tour d'espagne
très entouré très recherchée donne des
conférences de presse mais il reste
calme
et c'est sans esprit de revanche qu'il
revient sur ce tour un bon tour c'est
également ce que voudraient refaire
laurent fignon pour la première fois
depuis 1984 et des deux nouveaux de la
taille des plus grands c'est victoire
dans milan san remo et le tour d'italie
en font un grand favori et ils
apprécient
j'ai pas été malade de l'année donc j'ai
en marche comme qu'on aura du marché
enfin trouble-fête attendu charly mottet
et son compère et coéquipier le champion
de france eric caritoux autant d'hommes
en forme peut en tour 1989 très ouvert
vérifications dès demain c'est pourquoi
vous avez rendez vous d'un samedi
patients à partir de 16h30 pour suivre
ce prologue en direct un deuxième
rendez-vous vous attend de 19h30 à 20h
pour le journal du tour tout ce qu'il
faut savoir sur l'étape
notez bien ce sera tous les jours sur
antenne 2 jusqu'au 23 juillet c'est noté
prost cet acte wimbledon le train train
et les rugbymen français sont en pleine
forme pour leur prochain test match aux
antipodes
olivier rey
l'étonnant vainqueur de roland garros
l'américain michael chang a confirmé cet
après midi sur le gazon de wimbledon sa
victoire acquise en quarts de finale à
paris sur l'haïtien ronald agenor chang
s'est imposé en quatre sets 4 6 6 2 6 1
7 5
il affrontera au troisième tour le
néerlandais chapters vainqueur de
l'équatorien gomez chez les femmes
navratilova et sanchez vainqueur à
roland garros se sont qualifiés pour le
prochain tour
c'est très certainement à l'occasion du
grand prix de france au castelet la
semaine prochaine qu'alain prost
annoncera officiellement la suite qu'il
entend donner à sa carrière
il a cet après-midi démentie par
l'intermédiaire de ses avocats
l'information selon laquelle il
quitterait mclaren à la fin de la saison
pour l'écurie williams-renault il semble
bien pourtant que l'on se dirige vers
cette solution
mais pour le moment proches et toujours
chez mclaren suite au prochain grand
prix
il y a dix ans le 14 juillet 79
le quinze de france décroché une
victoire historique sur les all blacks
cette nuit à auckland l'équipe de france
essayera de renouveler cet exploit
battu lors du premier test match les
français se veulent optimistes avec
serge blanco à sa tête le quinze de
france a montré en seconde mi temps lors
du premier test match qu'il possède des
moyens de battre les all blacks répond
sur antenne 2 en direct d'auckland
samedi matin à 4h55 sur des commentaires
de pierre salviac et pierre albaladejo
antennes de la chaîne du sport
la légion d'honneur cet après midi à
l'elysée georges cravenne le réalisateur
celui qui fait de la remise des césar
français
un film a été élevé au grade de
commandeur dans cet ordre décorations
remises bien sûr par le président de la
république françois mitterrand
cet après midi à l'elysée elvire popesco
l'artiste dramatique d'origine roumaine
elle a débuté en 1910 au théâtre
national de bucarest avant d'asseoir à
partir de 1923 sa réputation sur les
scènes de théâtre à paris elle est
également faite cet après midi
commandeur de la légion d'honneur
elvire popesco dans ses diversités pour
le 9e festival de montpellier les
français sont là mais aussi une
compagnie soviétique pour la première
fois en france le ballet de minsk c'est
en biélorussie attendue également une
troupe africaine
arrivé de londres extrait musique et
danse qui aura grégoire michel levasseur
phase d'après midi à montpellier il fait
choux l'eau des fontaines rafraîchit le
fond de l'air animations de rues
habituel en période de festival
c'est donc soeurs font partie d'une cour
basée à londres leur but montrer que les
danses traditionnelles c'est aussi de la
danse exotique
c'est à dire pour nous un site en forme
d'art aussi valables que l'opéra que la
danse classique que la danse
contemporain et que nous vous y safran
pied que ça peut prendre forme comme un
autre forme d'art l'influent de la place
de montpellier rénover un festival de
l'oh diversifiés comme son architecture
35000 personnes en trois semaines le
festival a du succès et montpellier est
aussi centre national de chorégraphies
son directeur dominique bagouet fait
partie du fleuron de nos jeunes
chorégraphes français sa création
mondiale meublé sommairement est très
attendu
m
chanteurs invités pour la première fois
en france cette compagnie de ballet
soviétique où elle connut que le kirov
ou le bolchoï son chorégraphe et
directeur de la troupe se veut plus
moderne que celle où soeur travaille sur
une autre forme chorégraphique un peu
moins pleines grâce à la politique
actuelle je vais pouvoir m'exprimer
complètement
et puis on peut voir le changement
puisque je suis ici
pas de deux et pubs real à béjart mais
une vision très rétro genre 6,6 de faire
mal
la glace nost a encore beaucoup à faire
festival de montpellier demain à tiercé
quarté + à evry voici les pronostics de
pierrette brès 13 partants 5 3 4 6 12 13
10 et 1
dans un instant la météo avec que josé
bien la pierre c'est tout beau dimanche
dernier journal 22h57 henri sannier
édition du week-end de signer pradalier
bilalian et jean-claude allanic lundi à
cette même place
hervé claude excellente soirée à tous
sur antenne 2
oh